[inaudible].
So for you, for ion,
it's not just academic.
Where do you think the
bravery comes in for you? I,
cause I can tell there's nothing that
I could possibly ask you here that you
wouldn't give me the clearest,
honest answer.
And that isn't always how it is with
everybody, obviously as an interviewer.
But where do you think that comes from?
Candor as well as being one of
my greatest weaknesses. I think
I was probably brought up in a rather
combative family in a rather competence
part of the world. I grew up in, in
Glasgow, in the west of Scotland and
to a physician and a,
and a physics.
That's right. My mother was a physics
teacher. My father was a doctor. Yeah. Uh,
and they were the first in their
families to go to university.
My grandfathers had served
in the world wars. Uh,
Scots have a self image of
themselves as being a courageous.
The Scottish regiments were famous.
I wrote about this in my,
one of my earliest books. The busy of
war were famously the sharp end of,
of the British military.
Uh,
we marched towards the sound of gunfire.
Bagpipes playing.
That's the self image that uh,
a small Scottish boy growing up in the
1960s and seventies was encouraged to
have.
I remember vividly the
day that nine 11 happened.
I was sitting in Oxford
where I was then teaching,
but planning I'd planned and was
intending to fly to New York, uh,
very shortly to give a lecture on
nine 12 at New York University.
Uh,
indeed I was booked into a hotel very
close to the World Trade Center and my
response when I saw the attacks
was somewhat a bloody minded.
My response was very shortly afterwards
to resign my post docs for them go to
New York University and I
taught there for two years in a,
I suppose a mood of defiance that the
attempt to terrorize would not terrorize
me when I met a on a nine
more than nine years ago now,
it never crossed my mind
as I fell in love with her,
which happened very fast,
that this implied some meaningful,
a threat to my person.
Even when the FBI came to tell me that
there had been a threat against me,
something that I'd seen them due to
a on them more than one occasion.
I never gave it a second thought because
obviously my calling different from my
grandfathers who were called
to fight in real wars.
My more much more manageable
callings is to protect her.
She's one of the great heroines of our
time and extraordinary courageous woman
who's been through a hell of a lot and
who has never shirked from seeing what
she believes is wrong with modern Islam.
So it,
it is second nature to me to
be there with her in that,
in that fight, in that war, that's
what it turns out to be. My warm,
I always used to wonder
as I was growing up,
why is it that my generation isn't really
been called on to fight wars the way
my grandfather's generations were
called on and then it turned up.
Then my water turned up.
You briefly mentioned this earlier when
you're talking about ion and Brandeis,
but can you explain this intersection
of Islamism and the left,
how, why this has occurred?
This confuses a lot of people,
this idea of the oppression
Olympics and you know,
I've got plenty of theories on
this that we've knocked out, but,
but what do you think it is that has
attracted something that is completely
totalitarian and control with another
thing that's so completely total? I mean,
I guess that's the answer right there.
Well, there are many unholy
alliances in, in history and uh,
no don't. Many people will gravely, uh,
surprised when the Ribbentrop Molotov pat
was announced and the Soviet Union and
Nazi Germany formed an alliance.
So we shouldn't be entirely surprised
when seemingly odd bedfellows jump into
bed.
In the case of the Islamists and the left,
I think it's pretty clear to
me that the Islamists are the,
the leading partner and the leftists are
broadly the useful idiots because the
Islamists have a strategy.
It's there in Muslim Brotherhood and other
documents for expanding their network
in the west.
And part of the strategy is the kind of
a partnership that they have formed on
campuses against, uh, against her foes.
One way in which this works is
that you use the issue of Israel,
uh,
to forge the packs with the left.
So you get the left's longstanding
animosity towards Zionism,
uh, and you essentially say, well, we
entirely agree with you about that. Let's,
let's have an event about
how wicked Israel is. Uh,
and so that's the gateway
drug into accepting.
The next thing is, well, headscarves
are actually empowering for women,
don't you think?
Uh,
and isn't it actually Islamophobia
to be in any way of Sharia law.
So you play the multiculturalists
cultural relativist card, uh,
and you again depict any critics
of radical Islam as it, as in fact,
uh, engaged in some kind
of orientalist project, uh,
or essential list project to other people.
Always talk about othering
and academia, uh, Muslims.
And you blur the
distinction between Islam,
Islamism and Muslims as people.
So this has been going on for awhile
and the left has broadly fallen for it.
And it, to me, it's just astonishing.
I remember looking at the
list of academics who had,
who had argued that I aren't,
should not receive an honorary degree at
Brandeis and it included professors of
Queer Studies, uh, female professors
of gender studies. It's incredible.
You kind of feel like
saying to these people,
have you taken a look at what the Muslim
Brotherhood envisages have you read
Khatibs works?
Do you realize that the project is the
permanent demotion of women to second
class status and potentially a
capital punishment for gays? Is,
is that something you are aware of?
And I can only conclude that
they aren't aware of it and,
and have been very thoroughly duped
as useful. Idiots usually are.
So it was that basically, because
both of these movements want power.
So the useful idiot part of this is that
Islam is a really just using the left
who attain power and they're doing it
all in the name of diversity and all of
these things. And eventually
once that power is attained,
then for lack of a better expression,
I mean,
you basically decapitate them and
then you've got, they did it for you.
They did the work for you. Yes. I mean,
I always used to joke with ion that,
uh,
when we lived in Cambridge,
it would be fun if all my enemies and all
her enemies came and protested outside
our house together because
after about 20 minutes a day,
they'd fall on one another and they
would be the most tremendous fight.
I do think that power is part of it,
but if one looks back at the
history of another intolerance,
totalitarian ideology of Marxism,
there's a combination of power
and are a kind of idealism,
one must call it that, uh,
in the square in the Torah.
I tell the story of how the Soviet
successfully penetrated the British
establishment by recruiting spies and
Cambridge and the people they recruited
had leanings to the left
that were inspired partly by
revulsion at those aspects
of,
of British imperialism or British
class society that work in many ways a
legitimately open to criticism.
There was an idealism there
at the beginning of guide
Burgess's involvement in
Marxism, sympathy with workers during
the time of the Great Depression,
but those were the useful idiots that the
Soviet cynically recruited to be spies
who, whom they persuaded to betray their
countrymen in what was the single most
successful act of,
of Russian espionage of them
all recruiting these highly
educated people from an
incredibly exclusive network,
the Cambridge Apostles and the related
network that led to Bloomsbury.
This was a brilliant strategy.
Something similar is going on here
because I think there are great many naive
young people who are drawn to
the rhetoric of social justice.
I encounter them often,
people who say, oh,
there should be limits on free speech
because I don't want such and such, uh,
such and such as feelings to be hurt. And
then naive. They have a very naive view.
Somehow that can be a circumscribed
form of free speech and know in which
nobody's feelings get hurt.
That's not the pursuit of power.
That's just naive city.
And the people who know how to exploit
that naive city are both people amongst
the Islamists and people amongst
the leftists who are pursuing power.
But you can never really get to power
without the useful idiots without the
naive idealists who think that they're
going to build utopia with your hell.
Yeah. And I don't have to
tell you, they're usually ends
up in dystopia. Right. So,
and that's, that's something that
is hard to persuade people of your,
I keep reflecting on
the curious revival of,
of Margaret Atwood's the Handmaid's tale,
which is always taken to be a vision
of what happens when right wing people,
uh, take over America. And to me,
the amazing thing that is almost
never observed is that, uh,
something very like this has happened.
It happened in Iran after 1979 and it
happened after the Taliban came to power
enough Ghana's Stan.
So we don't need to fantasize about
crazy evangelical fascists turning women
into baby machines. This has already
happened, but it was done by Islamists.
It was done by people pursuing
an extreme version of,
of Sharia. And yet almost
nobody who enthuses about, uh,
Margaret Atwood's book realizes that
it is actually really quite powerful
realization of what a theocratic
Islam as regime does to women.
All right. So I want to shift gears
a little bit here and we can either,
I'm going to let you choose.
We can either go the historical root
or we can go the present route. Where,
where are you feeling first?
I do want to do both.
I think the key to applied history,
which is what I've spent my whole life
doing is that you do both and you can't
do one without the other because no,
you can have no real insight about
the present without the past.
So why don't we talk about the president
and our try to show why to understand
that you need history. All
right, very good. So, uh,
there are a couple of
things that are interesting
that you've, you've staked out positions
out over the past couple of years. Uh,
we briefly, right before we sat down,
we talked about Brexit for a second.
So you originally were for,
were against Brexit. Yeah.
Then you came around for it. Now it seems
to be in this odd limbo that I think,
unfortunately, most people in
America don't even understand what's,
what's going on. I don't think most people
in Britain on this plan. I'm sure. Um,
so when I was reading your position
on this, I at first I thought,
well wait a minute.
As a,
as a conservative and as someone that
wants some autonomy over his country,
I was somewhat surprised actually
that you weren't for it originally.
So can you explain your original position
and then how you changed on that?
The two reasons, um, while
I was on the side of remain,
remain in the EU, uh, back in 2016,
one was pure personal loyalty to friends.
Uh,
David Cameron was prime minister.
George Osborne was chancellor of the
Exchequer and they are friends of mine.
And I,
I felt obliged as a friend to
support them when they decided,
uh, to stick with the EU
and not to recommend Brexit.
Did,
did that friendship supersede what your
feelings were or was that because you
really trust
well, that was, they could
get it done. The swung. Okay.
And I think the reason
that I was willing to, to,
to get on board with Romaine was that I
found that arguments of the Brexiteers
deeply unconvincing.
Uh,
I remember one night sitting down and
reading a lot of stuff by Daniel Hannon,
one of the deeding advocates
of, uh, of leaving.
And I remember thinking that
this was just intellectually,
completely third class and unconvincing
the s the notion that Britain would be
better off economically
outside the European Union,
wouldn't have passed muster
as, uh, an undergraduate paper,
nevermind a graduate of paper.
So I felt that the Brexiteers case
failed intellectually because they were
claiming implausibly I thought
that you could have a free lunch,
that you could leave the
European Union and be better off.
And that just seemed to me to be
intellectually completely deceitful.
I think it would have been harder
for me if they had said, honestly,
this is going to cost quite a bit,
but it's worth it because if we leave,
then we shall have the ability
to control our borders.
Uh,
and we shall have a autonomy at a time
when Europe is pursuing a federalist
course. But that wasn't the argument.
The argument was that at the area,
cause [inaudible] here are going to
get the money. This was the argument.
We get together,
money that we give to the European Union
and we'll get to build spend on the
national health service cause we will be
in fact better off. And that was a lie.
And I'm not good with lies. It was
a clever lie. It works politically.
And I give credit to Dominic Cummings
for crafting a message that was a PD both
to conservatives until the voters,
the Conservatives got immigration control,
Labor voters got the national
health service, gets the money.
So this was brilliant politically, but it
was mendacious I think heart. And so I,
I oppose the, uh, Brexit when it happened.
Uh,
what struck me in the subsequent
months was that while I had been,
while I had been on the side that lost,
there was a good reason why we lost.
And the good reason was that
we went around saying how
much it was going to cost.
And I think we were right about that.
I think ultimately,
at least some of what the Treasury said,
we'll try,
we'll turn out to be true about the cost.
But that wasn't what people cared about.
And when you went into pubs, as I did in,
in in Wales, in England, and in Scotland,
there was a question to which you could
not give an honest answer without losing
the debate.
And I'll tell you what that question was
because I was asked it multiple times.
You'd make the case about the cost.
Nobody was interested in the cost.
They would say, listen, Neil,
about the 1.3 million Muslims,
the Germans have just let in to Germany,
because that had just happened.
If the Germans give them German passports,
can they come here?
And the only honest answer
to that question was yes.
Yeah.
So immigration was the issue.
And I think for a significant number
of people are in England and Wales
especially, was less so in
Scotland where Brexit was defeated.
The realization was that Britain
had lost control of immigration,
that people had been promised net
migration in the tens of thousands in the
1990s under the Blair government.
And they'd ended up with net migration
in the hundreds of thousands.
They saw the chaos in Germany.
They saw the waves of migration
coming on and from Syria,
but from all over North Africa and uh,
and even South Asia. And they said,
and I remember David Cameron using this
phrase, get me out of here. And that was,
that was the driving
motivation for the Brexit vote.
And I think it was legitimate because
I think that Angela Merkel had made a
catastrophic mistake in
throwing open the gates.
I think it will have dark
consequences for the future of,
of Germany and of Europe. And I do
not blame British voters for saying,
forget about the cost of Brexit.
We really need to get out of this.
So I take, took the view by the
end of 2016 that you had to,
you had to respect the fact that ordinary
people had cut through the crap of the
debate and had got to the
heart of the matter are.
And the heart of the matter wasn't the
cost of Brexit. Uh, which is what I had,
I think mistakenly focused
on prior to the reference.
What was it like you as a
public person and you know,
someone that writes about this stuff
and puts your opinions out there to,
to have that realization. I think it's
very important if you write regularly,
if you are what we call a
public intellectual, uh,
to be willing to admit
that you've been wrong.
I think you have to be prepared
to say I was wrong. And I,
I think I was wrong in the sense
that what I wish I had done
looking back was,
I wish I had said to David Cameron and
George Osborne in the spring of 2016 when
it was clear that the Europeans were
going to make no meaningful concession on
the immigration issue when they basically
sent an insulting proposal about what
could be done about migration.
That was the moment I should have said
to Cameron and Osborne, forget it. Yeah,
you should campaign for Brexit if
that's all they're going to offer you.
If they're so completely oblivious to
the very real concerns about immigration,
then you should campaign for Brexit
instead of which we stuck with it.
And that was,
that was David Cameron's great mistake.
He should have said at that moment,
if that's all you've got,
I'm going to recommend Brexit
to the voters and it would
have saved him too. So,
so you'd think it was just
a bad negotiating ploy that
he just didn't use some
leverage to say we're going to have
to walk away from this. There was,
there was a moment when he should have
walked away and I should have advised
them to walk away.
So yeah,
I think one has to recognize when one's
made a mistake with such consequences.
The second thing,
which is worth knowing about this is
that the people who then inherited power
after the fall of Cameron and Osborne,
we're not the people who had
campaigned for and one on Brexit.
It was people who'd been on the remain
side. Theresa May became prime minister.
Uh,
I always knew that would be a disaster.
I did not have high regard for
her prior to the referendum.
The Daily Mail essentially put her in
that position and also Boris Johnson,
Michael Gove and others because they
bungled, uh, the leadership contest.
So we then ended up with
a terrible combination,
which was a commitment to Brexit,
but it's execution in the hands
of people who had been remainers.
And I think the result is the worst
of both worlds because right now we
essentially have the
psychological reality of Brexit.
I think British public to a large
extent has accepted that we are leaving,
but the execution is a total mess
by invoking article 50 early on,
the UK in essentially seeded the,
the power and the divorce to the European
Union and the concessions have come
one after another.
Ever since then.
And we now find ourselves in the odd
predicament that I think Theresa May is
saying that Brexit means you cease to be
a voting member of the European Union,
but you remain within the customs union,
potentially even within the single
market and you accept all the rules and
regulations of the European Union.
You just don't have any power.
If that's the end game,
then it's a disaster.
So the people that are trying to stop
this now, they want to invoke some,
some pretty crazy extreme stuff, right?
I mean there would be some really,
very rarely if ever used rules,
am I right about this that would actually
allow this to allow the stay to occur?
Well Anderson, I think those games
without getting into all of them,
I knew everything.
There is a level of complexity in
the discussions now in London that is
bewildering to most ordinary British
people when people start talking about Max
Fac and the customs
union or the complexity.
That's why it's such a confusing way.
Cause I discussed it with Douglas Murray
and he was even a little confused.
So it's actually not confusing in the
sense that what is happening is that
Theresa May is trying to get Britain to
accept the realities of belonging to the
European Customs Union,
which would preclude Britain
having its own trade policy,
uh, with our leaving the European
Union's decision making body.
So essentially in that
version, Brexit is just, uh,
you have the responsibilities, you
just don't have any power anymore. Uh,
which is definitely not what the British
public was told that it was getting in,
in Brexit. Uh, the,
the bigger problem in my mind is,
is not one that,
that we've discussed.
And that is that all of this will end
in tears to the point at which Jeremy
Corbyn,
the most left wing leader of the Labour
party has ever had in its history,
becomes prime minister because to Reesa
Mae is leading the country towards this
very unhappy compromise. At some point,
the people who truly believe in Brexit,
Jacob Riis smog, uh, for example,
uh, perhaps Michael Gove,
uh,
they may decide we can't ultimately
accept this and the government may fall.
But the problem is that
if the government falls,
then Jeremy Corbyn has prime minister.
If the government doesn't fall and we go
all the way to the finishing line with
this Theresa May version of Brexit,
then I think the Conservatives will
lose the next election in 2022,
and Jeremy Corbyn will be prime minister.
So the worst there about
Brexit is in my view,
that if it is bungled in this way,
it will open the door to a
truly leftist government.
And that will be far more economically
damaging than anything Brexit has done.
And that's the nightmare scenario for
me and probably socially damaging and
finger zillion other reasons deeply.
We are,
we should be extremely suspicious
of Corban and his people.
They are committed Marxists.
They've been on the wrong side of every
issue in my lifetime with a possible
exception of South African apartheid.
And I do not trust them with the keys to
10 Downing Street because I think that
their ultimate agenda is a
truly revolutionary one. Uh,
and it poses a threat to
the fundamental liberties,
the traditions of the constitution.
It's a dangerous, dangerous prospect.
And I'm much more worried
about Corban that about Brexit.
I mean,
this is how I feel about what's happening
with our left in America through that.
You guys are giving us basically
the precursor to this. I think
one of the lessons of history and now
we can bring history in is that with
populism, you, you get two flavors.
In a typical backlash that would
come after a financial crisis,
uh,
the political establishment discredited.
There's a backlash against,
uh, inequality, uh,
all of the things that typically
follow a financial crisis,
but there are two possibilities.
There's the populism of the left,
which is the tax,
the rich solution,
but the populism of the writers more
potent because it says that it's about
immigration, it's about
globalization, it's about free trade.
And so broadly speaking,
there's a very good study that shows
this after big financial crises,
the populace of the right do better
because they offer a more plausible story.
But if they don't deliver and they
generally don't cause quite hard to make
immigration control and terrorists
pay quite hard actually to make your
constituents better off
with those policies,
then the pendulum has a tendency to
swing to the populism of the left.
And that has happened in Britain really
quick because Corbyn became popular very
soon after Brexit.
It's slower here,
but the fear must be that if the Trump
experiment goes as wrong as the vast
majority of of intellectuals expect it to,
the pendulum will swing to the
left of the Democratic Party.
And that scenario seems to me
more and more plausible are,
and I don't think that's a,
that's a not an appetizing. Yeah,
I mean that, that, that's
genuinely scary to me.
But I want to back up for one second
because the moment that you had that,
you said a few times happened in these
pubs when you would go there and people
would say this about 1.3
million Muslims in Germany,
how do you, so okay, so if you were
listening to the mainstream media,
they would say these people are all
racist. That's what they would tell you.
They're,
they're racists and they're bigots.
I suspect that's not what
you think of these people.
Although there probably was a certain
amount of people that are just racist and
don't like people of a different
color or a different culture.
How do you even have that conversation?
Because that's what's so much
of this is about, cause you,
I'm sure it would have a pint with these
people and you talk to them and realize
that they weren't racist. They were
actually just worried about their future,
which is legit.
But if you can't have that discussion
because every time you open your mouth
they tell you you're racist. Well then
we know what you end up with. Look,
I would be a very strange,
if I took a bigger view on the
subject because I'm an immigrant,
I'm an factor about to become
an American citizen. Uh,
in a matter of weeks.
My wife was a refugee who go from,
um,
uh,
Somali originally to the
Netherlands by applying for asylum.
Uh,
and so we would be the last couple to
take a kind of a bigoted view on the
immigration issue
because we are the grids.
When I had conversations on this subject
at the time of the Brexit referendum,
I remember realizing that the opposition
to immigration was not plausibly a
racist because I remember somebody making
the point that he was as worried about
the people from Lithuania and Poland
coming to Britain as he was about people
from Syria and Iraq. And, uh,
and you probably know that people
from Poland Lithuania, a pretty white.
So here's the thing,
what we all need to recognize is
that if immigration shoots up,
if it grows from,
in the case of Britain,
10,000 or 20,000 a year to
200,000 to 300,000 a year,
perfectly unprejudiced people will say,
that's too much.
This is going too fast.
And that I think was
the dominant argument.
Of course there are people who
are racists in any society,
but the striking thing about Britain is
actually that it's not a terribly racist
place.
Did you see many people protesting against
Prince Harry's decision to marry an
American of mixed mixed race? I was there
a couple of days before the Bolivarian.
There were huge crowds.
Uh,
this matches extraordinary
popular with ordinary people.
So I think it's hard to argue that
racism played any meaningful part are the
white supremacist elements in Britain
is really, is really very insignificant.
And actually one of the ways in which
the British like to define themselves is
as being tolerant,
uh,
memories of the war of not entirely faded,
even as the wartime generation
gradually disappears from the scene.
What was the war against Germany?
About it was a war against
the ultimate racist state.
What hurt Jeremy Corban the most
in the last three or four months?
The evidence that there are antisemitic
elements within his faction of the Labor
left that hurt him.
And it's important that that argument
keep being made because it has real truth
to it. And I think ordinary
people think that's not good.
So I, I think this is not really
about racism. It's not about bigotry.
It's about how rapidly
should immigration occur,
how large should flows be across borders.
And the lesson of history is that if
you allow a real surge in immigration,
there will be a populist backlash against
is what happened in the United States
in the late 19th century.
The peak in the 1880s the foreign born
percentage of the population in the US
was about 14% and gone up
from relatively low level,
it's about 14% same thing
has happened in our time.
It was down I think below
7% in the mid 20th century.
In the period after World
War II immigrants, we're a
relatively small proportion.
NATO foreign born citizens were pretty
small portion of the US population.
And then from the 1980s onwards,
the proportion surged and the
character of the immigrants changed,
uh, that the places that
they came from change.
And these changes are
bound to elicit a reaction.
It always happens and it's not enough
for people in the liberal elites who by
and large don't live in areas where
immigrants and come to say what a terrible
deplorable bunch of chauvinists you are
for not wanting for not wanting more
immigrants. That's simply, that's
simply historically stupid. Uh,
and the other thing that stupid about
this in the United States is, uh,
the people on the left who want
to legitimize illegal immigration.
I think for many people who
were attracted to Trump,
the issue was the illegal
quality of the immigration.
The rule of law is a big deal
in the English speaking world.
And people don't like to hear anything
that simply says amnesty for lawbreakers.
Well, if you're a law abiding citizen
and you're suddenly told, well,
yet the law applies to you,
but there are these other people,
it's not going to apply to you. Then
your natural reaction is, screw this.
That's why I thought one of his best
lines, he doesn't use it as much anymore.
But during the campaign where
either a country or we're not,
I thought was a really effective line.
You either have laws or you don't. I mean,
that in essence is the
truth. So let, let's shift to
Trump a little bit here. Um,
I think that we're kind of
in a similar spot with him,
which is that it's better
than the alternative.
That that's certainly
how I feel at this point,
that all of the forces that we've spent
the last hour plus talking about would
be that much more emboldened against
free thought and all and free expression
and open inquiry and all the things that
we care about and historical fact and,
and everything else.
If he was in president right now,
I am deeply ambivalent about all of this.
I think it's,
it's very, very hard, uh, to say,
uh,
a good word about the
personality of Donald Trump.
I'm with you. I, it was a reason that I,
I found it impossible
to support him in 2016.
I think one has to
acknowledge that he has,
uh, used inflammatory language, uh,
on the issues we've talked
about immigration, uh,
that he has a record of, of, of lying,
which is,
uh,
even by the standards
of American presidents.
Pretty remarkable.
Uh,
and so the familiar list of things about
Donald Trump that most of my friends
find objectionable is Kinda
hard for me to, to dismiss.
But I said I'm ambivalent for a reason.
On the other hand,
number one,
what if he lost?
I said this to Sam Harris a few weeks ago.
Let's run the counter factual.
This is what historians should do.
Let's imagine an alternative history.
If Donald Trump had lost
the election by let's say,
the same narrow margin that he wanted it,
how would all those people who voted
for him have felt and how would they
behaved?
To my mind,
the election of Donald Trump
is a cathartic moment for
those people so despised
by the liberal elites that they
could refer to them as deplorables.
The people who voted for Donald Trump
are not by and large are racists,
are not by and large, uh, uh,
anything like Donald Trump is personally.
What attracted them to
Trump were two things,
which as with the Brexit campaign
will legitimate number one,
they were attracted to Trump's
policy positions on trade,
on immigration, on Islam, at and on, uh,
the somewhat corrupt liberal elite that
had been run in the country for the
previous eight years. So I think they were
attracted to Trump's policy positions,
but they were also attracted
to his cultural position.
And I think about half of
American populism is cultural.
What attracted the friends I have
who supported Trump to Trump was his
fundamental shift in language,
away from the politically correct
talking points of the political class,
Republicans and Democrats alike to
a demotic normal way of speaking,
such as you would here in
the typical American bar,
more or less anywhere in the country
except Cambridge, Massachusetts, Stanford,
California, and the rest. Now I,
I remember thinking on
the eve of the election,
if you line up all the people who are
going to vote for her and you line up all
the people who are going to vote for him,
which line would you rather be in?
Remember at that point, I'm not
a citizen. I don't have a vote,
and I thought that's easy.
I'm with the people who are so pissed
with the political establishment that
they're ready to take a chance on this
guy because they see no other way to
shake things up the way.
My friend Jerry Blake put it to me,
Ex Marine Corps Xn YPD
never went to college,
helps take care of my wife's security.
Jerry said to me early 2016 two
things that stuck in my mind for us.
He told me Trump was going to win,
but then he said the two reasons
why he supported Trump. Number One,
he tells it like it is.
Number two,
he's going to shake things up by,
he tells it like it is.
Jared did not mean he is always truthful.
What he meant was he talks like me
by shaking things up, Jerry men,
we have to do something because the system
as it stands is not in my interests.
It's not in my interests economically
because it seems to favor China over the
United States, Mexicans,
overt, native born Americans,
the rich 1% over me, the median
household. But he's also,
it's also about this cultural reaction
against the multiculturalism that has
become the orthodoxy of the liberal left.
So for all my reservations about Trump,
I completely got why people voted for him.
And I think their reaction had
he lost would have been toxic.
I don't think they would have
accepted the legitimacy of the result.
I think they would have bought the story.
Trump would have told them that
the election had been rigged,
and I think we would've had a poisoned
body politic from day one of a Clinton
presidency. If it all ends, oddly
though we're having that right now,
just in the reverse, right.
It would have been worse,
but we're having a left that's not
accepting the legitimacy of the election,
and I think it would have been worse.
Yeah, I think it would've been worse.
Uh,
and I think,
and this is another part of the story
that for Jerian his and his many,
many fellow Americans who voted Trump,
this has always been a gamble and they've
always had a sense that it could go
wrong. You know, when you shake
things up, sometimes they break.
And I s I sense that if
it all ends in fiasco,
which I guess that the vast majority
of public intellectuals expect,
and some combination of
Watergate and other scandals,
I think Jerry and his and his fellow
American Trump supporters will say, well,
we gave it a try. Give it
a try. And I think that's,
that's one possible scenario.
The other reason that I am ambivalent
about Trump is that for all his flaws,
in some ways he's doing a better job,
uh,
on foreign policy than
his predecessor did. Uh,
because Trump has this superpower that
most intellectuals can't understand,
he has an unerring instinct for the
weakness of the counterparty that it's a
kind of,
almost animal instinct.
But some are Donald Trump can
tell when the other side is weak.
You could see it in Jeb Bush,
she could see it in Marco Rubio,
could see it in Hillary Clinton. And
now I think he sees it in the Europeans.
He sees in Angola Merkel,
you don't pay enough for your defense.
What if I walk out on NATO?
Yeah,
well there's a season interview Kim
Jong than he sees it in Xi Jinping.
He sees it in the, uh, in
the supreme leader in Neuron.
So my ambivalence is partly by
sympathy for Trump supporters.
My fundamental sense of
why they voted for him.
But it's also that in some ways,
this disruption has its plus side in the
way that it's repositioning the United
States. I mean, I, to me,
it's given oxygen to everything that
we've talked about here. And that doesn't,
that doesn't discount all of the
legitimate concerns that you look.
The big concern for me,
as I mentioned before,
is that the pendulum swings the other way.
If this all ends in tears,
all of those who defended it,
even if they defended it half hearted,
they like me, will be discredited.
And the damage will be irreparable,
uh,
for conservatives and populists alike.
The left we empowered and they will spend
the rest of our lives telling us that
we were apologists for the
worst president. And that's,
that's not a scenario that you
can discount likely for a time.
I think it was exhilarating,
are freely admit that for me,
one of the most satisfying aspects of
Trump's victory was that all the people I
most dislike in this contract,
we're in a state of hysteria and shock
for weeks. And I remember things that are,
you know,
it can't be all bad if the people I
really can't stand or in this state,
but you have to,
I think with history in mind,
be conscious of the dangers of the fact
that this could end so badly that it
does irreparable damage.
And,
and the worst damage of all will be if
it propels the left of the Democratic
Party into power. And that, that
you can't rule out, you call.
The worst thing about studying history
is that it makes you aware of how under
terministic their historical processes,
that there is always more than one future.
There's the future of triumph.
There's the future of tragedy.
And there's this kind of
other future in the middle,
which is a little bit of both.
And that's really one of the historical
moment is bad for restful sleep on wakes
up in the morning.
And I'm sure you have the same feeling
wondering what alert will be on your
phone and what message
will be on your phone.
Will the alerts say war has broken out?
Will the alerts say are palace
coup and will the message say,
uh, you'll reputation has just been, uh,
been destroyed by some
accusation or other.
So one wakes up in a state of
anxiety in the United States of,
of 2018.
And that is a,
is a reality for that I think is inherent.
Both
the culture war that we've spoken
about and the Trump presidency,
which is in some measure a backlash
against that, that culture war.
We're going to leave it at that, but I
am going to demand that you come back.
I don't think I've ever demanded that.
I guess come back and ask,
but I'm legitimately
demanding that you come back.
Because next time I want to do,
I want to just do all history and we
can even break even out even barely jump
into, I want him to even some
prior stuff and Churchill and okay,
I'm demanding it. Will you accept
my demand? Except all right,
it took a long time to get here but,
but considering we're both two guys
just off planes today and you're like 87
hours out of whack and jet lag and all
those things we said we'll be taken out
of context on Twitter.
Well high gusts sincerely hope everything
because that's how you know the whole
thing goes.
This has truly,
truly been an absolute pleasure and thank
you for doing this and send my best of
course, Diane. Sure will.
And uh, for more on Neil,
you can follow him on the Twitter,
although you don't fight with people
that much on Twitter, which means,
which means you have
strong moral character.
I decided the jungle warfare
was not the way to go.
He's a wise man. And it's at n f e R G. U.
S.